Superhero movies come out every few months
now, but back in 1989? "Batman" was an event.
A milestone. Keep watching to relive that
special summer, or live it for the first time.
On hearing that a Batman film was on its way, fans
of the Dark Knight did not have their hopes up.
For one, the campy '60s Batman series was still
firmly established in the pop culture canon
even as more gritty interpretations were
making their way to the comic book pages.
Unfortunately — proving that nerd rage over
superhero castings pre-dates social media — the
news that Beetlejuice himself, Michael Keaton,
had been cast as Batman didn't help matters.
To be fair, the news of Keaton's
casting stunned everyone,
not just comic book fans. Even Batman executive
producer Michael Uslan claims to have initially
thought the casting news was a joke and
trades like Variety openly mocked the choice.
Fans started letter-writing campaigns to
change the studio's mind, including petitions.
"A little disappointing. Because I guess
if you've grown up watching the comics
and reading the comics and watching the TV
show it's a lot different than I expected."
Considering how many fans will still
tell you Keaton is their favorite Batman,
this kind of nerd rage may seem
inconceivable. But before you judge,
think about how the general public looked
at Michael Keaton in the '80s. At the time,
all of Keaton's most commercially successful
films — like "Beetlejuice" and "Mr. Mom" – were
comedies. So to understand how Batman fans
felt hearing Michael Keaton was playing Batman,
just imagine if an actor best known for his
sitcom work was cast in a superhero movie.
The hype surrounding the release
of 1989's Batman is the stuff of
legend. All you need for proof is the very
existence of so many online retrospectives
not necessarily about the film, but
specifically the phenomenon — often
referred to as "Batmania" at the time —
created by Warner Bros' media machine.
Forbes' Scott Mendelson writes about
being "consciously gripped in Bat-fever"
before the release of Batman. For ComicsAlliance,
Patrick A. Reed recalls the, quote, "candy-filled
Keaton heads in supermarket checkout aisles"
and the "Batmobile toys in Happy Meals," before
concluding that, quote, "the entire world had gone
Batty." The Washington Post remembers the hype
transforming the film into a "preordained event,"
and as a result yielding huge financial returns.
It worked: Batman raked in $43
million in its opening weekend,
breaking numerous ticket sales records,
including breaking the record for ticket
sales not only on opening weekend,
but for its second weekend too.
One of the simplest and most effective
marketing tools used to publicize Batman
was the black-and-gold Bat emblem that
was seemingly in every shop in 1989.
Whether you were at the supermarket buying
groceries, in a department store buying clothes,
or a fast food joint getting lunch,
the Batman logo was everywhere.
Part of the genius of Batman's marketing onslaught
was realizing how instantly iconic that bat logo
already was. It was not at all uncommon, for
example, to be met with the movie posters which
didn't even include the name "Batman," but simply
the black-and-gold bat logo and the release date,
June 23rd. Paul Levitz, DC Comics' executive
vice president and publisher in 1989,
joked that the Bat logo shirts were so successful
that it caused a shortage of black cotton.
The notion of using a superhero's logo
similarly in marketing has since become
practically mandatory, but in 1989 it was a
novel and effective use of iconic imagery.
Released the same month as Batman, the
late Prince's hit single "Batdance" was
as inescapable as any other Bat-related hype that
summer. At turns a chaotic dance song or a slow,
funky groove, "Batdance" is liberally
peppered with samples from the film,
including arguably the Joker's
most surprising exclamation,
"This town needs an enema!"
The single got a lot of negative reviews from
critics, but it still hit the top of the Billboard
charts in August 1989. And the video, like the
song, is striking, wild, and kind of incoherent.
Prince appears as himself in
kind of a Batcave-y music studio,
and as a character known as Gemini who
appears to be half-Batman and half-Joker.
Along with stoking the already
raging fire of Bat hype,
"Batdance" was a huge win for Prince. The
video won a Soul Train award and helped
make Prince's "Batman" soundtrack his first #1
album since 1985's "Around the World in a Day."
The notion that Batman is a darker
hero shouldn't feel like a revelation,
right? In the 21st century, if a
new Batman project is announced,
you can expect a gravelly-voiced vigilante who
makes himself a friend to shadows. He broods,
he mourns, and he finds gargoyles
to perch on wherever he goes.
It may surprise younger fans to know,
however, that before Tim Burton's Batman,
the Dark Knight's legacy was dominated
by the camp of the '60s Batman series.
Sure, the fans of the source material knew
Gotham's greatest champion had wider variety
in his stories than simply the over-the-top
parodies found in the television show. But
outside the comic book shop, most audiences
heard the name "Batman" and thought of Adam
West and Burt Ward climbing up walls
or their ridiculous fistfights with
the comic book sound effects like "POW"
and "BIFF" superimposed over the melee.
Curing pop culture of this association was one
of the goals of lifelong Batman fan Michael Uslan
in his decade-long crusade to get Batman made. In
the "Shadows of the Bat" documentary, Uslan says,
"For about 20 years, whenever anyone mentioned the
word 'Batman' [...] 'pow,' 'zap,' and 'wham' were
always attached to the name. I wanted to detach
it and get back to the heart of the character."
Considering the hero's more
contemporary adaptations,
it's clear 1989's "Batman" succeeded in forcing
the hero away from his days dancing the Batusi.
Just as "Batman" forced audiences
to deal with a Dark Knight who was
far more interested in vengeance than he was puns,
Jack Nicholson's portrayal of the Joker made
the world take the cackling maniac seriously.
While he may seem cartoonish compared to
grittier 21st century portrayals of the Joker,
Nicholson had a take on the character that was a
steep departure from what most audiences expected.
Sure, by 1989 Alan Moore and Brian Bolland's
"Batman: The Killing Joke" was making waves
at the comic book shop. But the live-action Joker
most people knew was played by Cesar Romero in the
1960s Batman series. Not only did Romero famously
refuse to even shave his mustache for the role,
but we are in no danger of being contradicted
when we point out that the hero of 1989's Batman
kills more people in that film than Romero's
Joker does in the entire '60s series.
There's no better proof that Nicholson is largely
responsible for the more complex directions
Joker has taken in the more contemporary
times than the complaints of the guy who
played him for two years. When the Associated
Press asked for his reaction to the 1989 film,
Cesar Romero called it, quote,
"dreary." Romero lamented,
"Nicholson, who is such a wonderful actor and
who has done such good work, is just so violent."
While there will probably always be naysayers,
the stories of comic book superheroes
slogged a long road toward any kind of
legitimacy — and 1989's Batman was one
of the biggest steps down that road.
In the "Shadows of the Bat" documentary,
Michael Uslan gives an example of how
superhero comics were viewed pre-Batman that still
would sound familiar to any fan of the genre.
While attending Indiana University
in the '70s, Uslan took advantage of
a program that allowed students to pitch
courses that they would teach themselves.
Uslan says when he applied to teach a course about
comic book heroes, the college dean told him comic
books were "cheap entertainment" and "junk" not
worthy of academic study. According to Uslan,
he responded by illustrating how the
origin story of Superman mirrored
that of the Biblical figure Moses, and as a
result his course was immediately approved.
"Batman's" success not only helped legitimize
superhero movies, but made them more attractive
to actors and directors. Speaking about
this to the Washington Post, Andrew Farago,
author and curator for San Francisco's
Cartoon Art Museum, listed visionary
directors who would later attach themselves
to superhero franchises, aptly wondering
"Who could have imagined a world
with Kenneth Branagh directing Thor?"
Along with their many Easter eggs, contemporary
superhero movies and TV shows are known for
teasing fans by introducing characters
who — should the adaptation of the source
material follow closely enough — could become
superheroes or villains in future stories.
For example, 2008's "Iron Man" hinted at James
Rhodes becoming the armored hero War Machine,
but fans had to wait one more movie for it.
"Next time, baby."
Batman gave us a very early example of this
kind of tease by casting Billy Dee Williams
as hero District Attorney Harvey Dent. Any DC
Comics fan in the theater knew that Dent was
destined to become the coin-tossing criminal
Two-Face. With this character's appearance,
the movie created a palpable sense among fans
that there was more to come, and did it without
pandering or shouting the reference from the
rooftops. And while the part would eventually
be recast with Tommy Lee Jones, the franchise
did end up making good on its promise of adding
Two-Face to Batman's rogues gallery in "Batman
Forever." Williams, meanwhile, eventually got
to play the role of Two-Face decades later
in the Lego Batman movie, of all places.
"Batman" also created that delicious sense
that there was more on the way through its
many absences. It was impossible not to ask
who would play Robin, who would play Riddler,
who would play Penguin when he eventually
showed up. Fans were casting the sequels
before the original was out of theaters
- and it was in theaters a long time.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.